[Music]
welcome back
okay you have
stuck with me
this far into the wilderness of complex
analysis so i commend you
um
we have just arrived the cauchy integral
formula
uh which really relies on a lot of
concepts uh in complex analysis like
analytic functions
kind of the multi-valued property of
logarithms and things like that it's a
pretty simple formula actually
and what i'm going to do now
is start to show you examples of kind of
cool and gnarly integrals that you can
solve pretty easily using
this formula and some of the other
things i showed you like the koshi gorsa
formula
okay
and i also recognize that a lot of you
who are watching
may very well
you know be taking a complex analysis
class and are being asked to do these
heinous integrals and so i'm there for
you
and i'm there with you i personally find
these to be pretty fun actually i think
it's kind of cool that you can do
uh these gnarly transformations using
these uh kind of building on this
infrastructure um that you know koshi
and gorsa and riemann and others
laid out you know a couple hundred years
ago so i'm gonna start with an example
i'll probably break this up i might
break this video up into like three or
four little examples so that they're
short i might make one big mega massive
uh all the examples we'll see
the first example i'm going to make real
easy um
so and this is essentially just an
example of how to use the koshi integral
formula
so let's say we have a function f of z
equals um
1 over
z squared
minus 3z
plus 2. i'm getting this basically
straight from my lecture notes i'll
probably post a link to the pdf
on
on these videos this is the function i'm
going to do
and we know that this uh we can break
this up we can factor this this
denominator into 1 over
z minus 1
times z minus 2. so we say that this
thing has singularities or poles
at poles
at z equals one and two so these kind of
first order singularities like one over
z minus a we call that point a a pole of
the system a pole of the system it says
first order singularity a pole and those
are the ones that have that kind of
important residue that integrates up to
something like two pi i okay you can
rewind to the previous lectures
uh to kind of see how this was derived
probably the last two lectures are the
important ones
um
so it's important to note
i'm just going to say note
1 over z minus 1 is analytic everywhere
except for z equals 1. so 1 over z minus
1 is
analytic
at
z equals 2 and similarly 1 over z minus
2 is analytic at z equals 1. they're
just not analytic 1 over z minus 1 is
not analytic at z equals 1 1 over z
minus 2 is not analytic at z equals 2.
uh
good and so the cauchy integral formula
will apply
if i'm integrating around z equals two
this part of the function uh the one
over z minus one is analytic at z equals
two and similarly if i'm integrating
around z equals one this part of the
function is analytic at z equals one and
so what i'm going to do is i'm actually
going to cook up uh three different
contour integrals and we're going to get
a feeling for how how to do this so
uh in the complex plane
right we have our real axis our
imaginary axis sorry i've been filming
for five hours straight i was going to
tell you
i've been doing complex analysis this is
a saturday we are about to move
our family and i have been following for
five hours straight so that's how with
you i am
in your complex analysis integral class
so uh pay attention because i might you
know i might make some some uh
i might have some issues depending on
how smoothly this goes
these are our poles at minus one and
minus two those are the only
singularities of this function f of z
and so i'm going to define a few
different contour integrals
and play around and show you how to use
this formula and other things we've
learned
so the first contour integral i'm going
to do let's make this blue
i'll do a contour integral around this
point we'll call that contour one
i'll do a contour integral around the
second point we'll call that contour two
i'm gonna do a contour
three
sorry it's so squeaky i know this drives
some of you crazy uh keeps me alive
okay this is going to be my contour 3.
it's going to surround both of these
singularities oh my goodness what's
going to happen and then i'm going to do
another contour contour 4 which doesn't
include either of those singularities
okay
now i think we know
to some extent that the integral around
contour four is going to equal zero
right because that was the original
um the original um
kind of koshi gorsa theorem or theorem
for analytic functions
this function f of z
is actually analytic here and so the
integral around this closed loop away
from these singularities around c4 is
going to equal zero we know that's true
from prior theorems
um let's talk about how to solve this
first integral c1 because that's really
what we're going to use the cauchy
integral formula for
so um
we're going to do this integral
of um
around c1
of f z
d z
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to say
that this is equal
to the integral around c1 that
singularity is z minus one
it is some function
which is one over z minus two which is
in fact analytic
around this point z equals
uh
i'm sorry this could be a plus one
and i told you how tired it was plus one
and plus two this is plus one in the
real direction plus two in the the
real direction are the two poles
um
so i'm going to break my function up
into one over z minus two that's kind of
this function that's analytic
divided by
z minus 1.
so in the cauchy integral formula
this top part the the numerator 1 over z
minus 2. that's going to be my function
that's analytic around
around this this base point a which is a
equals uh a equals one
and yeah so so essentially here we're
saying um
in this case you know a equals one in
the cauchy integral formula
so we can split this up into one over z
minus one
so a equals one
and the other part of the the
function one over z minus two that is
actually analytic near a equals a equals
one so this is analytic this part is not
and we integrate this up
we're going to get what pops out
hopefully is going to be 2 pi i
times this part of the function the
analytic part evaluated at z equals one
so if i plug in z equals one i get one
over minus one which is minus one so
this is minus two pi i
so i'm pretty sure that the integral of
c one around this point of this function
is minus two pi i that's how you use the
koshi integral formula okay
let's do the same thing for the second
contour c2
maybe i'll mix it up and i'll do
yellow
so if i now have the integral around c2
of f of z
d
z equals integral around c2 in this case
now the kind of a point the point that
my singularity occurs at is a equals two
and now i'm going to split this up the
opposite way so the part of this
function that's analytic at z equals two
is one over z minus one
so one over z minus one is actually
analytic at z equals two
divided by z
uh minus two
and so now i can use the cauchy integral
formula dz sorry this should have a dz
also
uh
d z
and that's gonna equal
two pi i
times
this function this analytic part of the
function evaluated at z equals two so if
i plug in z equals two here i get 1 over
1 so my f of a
is just times 1 so 2 pi i
so the integral around c 1 is 2 minus 2
pi i the integral around c 2
is plus 2 pi i
good
c3 is pretty interesting the way i think
about c3 is the following how do i want
to do this
[Music]
i'll show you how i think of of c3 this
is kind of um
using that surgery kind of procedure i
showed you so if i have
you know if i've got my complex plane
and i have my singular points here
and here
and i have c3 which was this curve c3
my function is analytic everywhere
outside of these two pink
crosses and so i can continuously deform
this c3 curve using the koshi gorsa
theorem
until it's essentially like this tiny
little orbit almost like a dumbbell
around
those two singularities so i have you
know this curve and this curve and then
i'm going you know left on the
straightaway and right on the
straightaway and if i deform those
enough these straight segments kind of
cancel out they kind of you know they're
super close to each other it's in an
analytic region so it's smooth and
differentiable there and so if i bring
them infinitely decimally close together
they cancel out
so c3 is really
the integral of
c3 of you know f of z dz
is really equal to the integral
of c1
plus the integral
of c2
you know plus these little intervals
this is you know c i
plus and c i minus and those are going
to cancel each other out so i'm not even
going to write them down here
but we know that
it's getting messy
we know that
the integral around loop 1 is minus 2 pi
i and the integral around loop 2 is plus
2 pi i so if i add those up if i shrink
wrap this down and i add up the residue
around this from this part of the kosher
integral formula and the residue from
this from this part of the cauchy
integral formula what i end up getting
is you know plus 2 pie i
minus 2 pi i cancels out so the integral
around c3 is equal to 0. those are the
kinds of tricks you can play in the
complex plane using things like koshi
gorsa and koshi integral formula so c1
is minus 2 pi i c 2 is plus 2 pi i c 3
they cancel out to 0 because they have
the same like equal and opposite
residues
um and c4 is kind of the easiest one the
integral around c4 of f z dz
equals zero because
f is analytic everywhere inside and on
that curve so we knew this from from the
earliest days
uh because it's analytic it solves koshi
riemann which means that this integral
has to add up to zero you could apply
greens you know green's
theorem and uh
koshi riemann makes this equal to zero
okay this is one example of how you use
cauchy integral formula to integrate you
know functions that have singularities
uh kind of you know at different places
around different different orbits okay
good
um we could not have deformed
c3 to not include those singularities
because you can't deform a continuous
orbit
through a singularity koshi gorsa only
allows you to deform in regions where
the function's analytic so you can't
cross through these red points so i
couldn't like
move the c2 over here it has to stay
kind of topologically surrounding that
that point okay so that's an important
point
okay this is one example we're just
going to kind of ramp up next example is
going to be a little gnarlier i might
have to erase my board twice
and then we're going to keep going i
probably have three more
examples of gnarly integrals so stay
tuned